-The committee investigating
Donald Trump's attempted coup
on January 6th
held its first
televised hearing tonight
and, in advance of that hearing,
more audio emerged
of a phone call
in which House GOP Leader
Kevin McCarthy said, in the days
after the insurrection,
that there should be
an investigation
into what happened
and the people responsible
should be held accountable,
which is notable, of course,
since McCarthy,
like most of his fellow
Republicans,
have since changed their tune
to appease Trump.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
We do not know exactly what
happened at the hearing tonight
because we are taping this
before it airs,
but I'm hoping they really
jazzed it up for TV
and invited
some surprise guests.
-I want to now introduce
our witnesses today
and swear them in.
Our first witness is...
-Rudy Giuliani!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm guessing you could trick
Rudy Giuliani
into going anywhere
if you put him
in a jack-in-a-box
costume like that.
[ Laughter ]
One day we're going to see
federal agents carrying him
out of his apartment building
in that costume.
[ As Giuliani ]
You guys promise we're going
to "America's Got Talent,"
right?
[ Laughter ]
In that case,
I'm going to crawl back
in my box
and go over the lyrics
to "Fireworks,"
so I don't embarrass myself.
[ Laughter ]
I'm guessing that didn't happen,
although,
we don't know for sure, since,
as of this taping,
we haven't seen the hearing,
which gives us something
in common
with viewers of Fox News,
which announced, in advance,
that it wouldn't be airing
the hearing live.
-Fox News making
a programing decision.
It's sticking with its
primetime lineup on Thursday --
Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity
This is instead of showing
the January 6th
Select Committee hearing
concerning
the Capitol Hill riot.
-Of course, Fox isn't airing it.
They're a key suspect in it.
[ Laughter ]
That would be like if Court TV's
coverage of the O.J. trial
had been hosted by O.J.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Whoops, sorry, fellas.
The mic keeps slipping
out of these leather gloves,
which fit perfectly.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they're too small.
Damn it! Cut!
No, not cut! Stop taping!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fox was an active participant
in spreading the big lie
that led to the attempted coup
and has since helped whitewash
and cover up what happened.
In fact, the January 6th
Committee has already revealed
private texts from Fox hosts,
like Laura Ingraham,
Sean Hannity,
and Brian Kilmeade
to Trump Chief of Staff
Frank Meadows
on the day of the riot.
Imagine if the committee
read those text messages
and then Fox cut back
to Hannity or Ingraham.
It'd be like watching
that "Planet Earth" clip
where the snakes
chase the iguana
and then, at the end, they cut
to an interview with the snakes.
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, look, I know it looks bad.
We were just trying to,
I don't know, help the iguana.
Look, it's the food chain!"
[ Laughter ]
In fact, we already know,
thanks to the
January 6th Committee,
not to take anything
Fox hosts state seriously,
since, behind the scenes,
they were privately imploring
Trump to quell the mob.
They knew it was his fault
and they knew he had the power
to stop it.
They won't say that in public,
but they did say it in private.
-Multiple Fox News hosts
knew the president needed
to act immediately.
They texted Mr. Meadows and he
has turned over those texts.
"Mark, the president needs
to tell people in the Capitol
to go home.
This is hurting all of us
He is destroying his legacy,"
Laura Ingraham wrote.
"Please get him on tv.
Destroying everything
you have accomplished,"
Brian Kilmeade texted.
"Can he make a statement.
Ask people to leave
the capital,"
Sean Hannity urged.
-First of all,
I'm shocked to learn
that Brian Kilmeade
is capable of texting at all.
[ Laughter ]
I just assume he does
all is communicating
via a tin can
attached to a string.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Second, and more importantly,
they all knew.
They said stuff like,
"This is hurting us all.
Destroying his legacy.
Can he ask people to leave?"
They were watching the ride
on TV, like the rest of us,
and they all knew it was bad
and that Trump could stop it,
just like the rest of us.
As you can see,
from these private texts,
they weren't sitting there,
thinking,
"This is just
a peaceful protest,"
or "This is all antifa's fault."
They knew Trump could stop it,
if he wanted to,
which makes them liars.
They don't even believe
their own bull[bleep].
In a way, it would at least
be more honest
if we found out that,
behind the scenes,
they were texting stuff like...
[ Laughter ]
And, by the way, they were not
the only Trump supporters
who were privately horrified
by the insurrection,
while publicly lying about it
or making excuses for it.
Just last night,
more bombshell audio
of GOP House Leader
Kevin McCarthy surfaced,
from the days
after the insurrection,
in which McCarthy was adamant
that there should be
a full investigation of the riot
and that whoever was responsible
should be punished.
And he even went so far
as to tell
his fellow Republicans
on that call
that he had personally
confronted Trump.
-Five days later,
McCarthy spoke to his members
and, again, it's on tape.
McCarthy said that he got
on the phone,
he talked to Trump,
and that he castigated him
and he told him
to call off the mob.
...was going on...
-I mean, I would imagine,
anytime you talk to Trump,
you have to be very loud
about it.
[ Laughter ]
The dude on the other end
of that phone call is so loud,
he routinely did
his press conferences next
to a roaring helicopter
[ Laughter ]
and we could still hear
every word he said.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, just look at his face.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He always looks like
the villain in an action movie
who realizes the hero
has defused the bomb.
[ As Trump ]
Damn you, Jean-Claude!
[ Laughter and applause ]
But even more revealing
than that part of the phone call
was the part where McCarthy
specifically went out of his way
to insist that the events
of January 6th
deserve a full investigation
and that the people responsible
should be held accountable.
-During that call,
McCarthy also is on tape vowing
to make someone pay
for the attack,
even raising the idea
of a bipartisan commission
to investigate.
-Strong words,
but then a few weeks later,
he was at Mar-a-Lago,
posing for this photo
with Donald Trump,
where they look like
rival strip club owners,
acting like nothing
ever happened.
[ Laughter ]
He basically yada yada yada'd
an attempted coup.
[ Laughter ]
On that phone call
you just heard,
just days
after the insurrection,
he literally said the words,
"We can't sweep this
under the rug."
And now, he's essentially
showing up to all his interviews
on Fox News
with a giant broom.
[ Laughter ]
Also, side note here,
but what is it with these guys
constantly
getting caught on tape
saying damning stuff?
Over the last six or so years,
I've honestly lost count
of the number of times
some Trump-adjacent doofus,
like Rudy or McCarthy,
or Trump himself has been
caught on tape,
directly contradicting something
they said in public.
Next, we're going to find out
that, behind the scenes,
Rudy Giuliani is actually
a very normal guy
who never makes this face.
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah,
yeah, we use that photo a lot.
[ Laughter ]
But do you know --
do you know what he's doing
in that photo?
He's taking a closer look.
[ Laughter ]
That's where we got the idea.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, we were like, "Oh."
[ Whistling ]
Secret tapes are going to emerge
of Rudy doing normal stuff,
like watching "Ozark"
or paying his cable bill
or checking into a hotel
looking like this.
[ As Giuliani ] Hello.
[ Laughter ]
My name is Rudy Giuliani.
I'm here to check in to the
actual Four Seasons Hotel,
for a normal vacation
with my normal wife,
who is not now,
nor has ever been, my cousin.
[ Laughter ]
So, in private,
McCarthy told
his fellow Republicans
the coup attempt couldn't be
swept under the rug.
Now, he's doing exactly that,
going on Fox
and trying to sweep it
under the rug
by slamming the investigation
as illegitimate
and claiming it shouldn't
even be happening.
-What they're doing
in this committee
is going after their
political foes, their opponents.
We've watched it time and again.
What we have found,
with one-party rule
of Democrats taking over
the House, the Senate,
and the presidency,
they use the power to go
after their political opponents,
instead of bringing down
gasoline prices.
Today, it has now doubled,
the gasoline price,
since President Biden
has taken office.
Are they going to have
any hearings on that?
-They always do this annoying
thing where they're like,
"People care more
about gas prices."
You know we're all capable
of caring
about more than one thing
at a time, right?
[ Laughter ]
I think people can focus
on an attack on democracy.
I mean, what else
are they going to do?
They can't drive anywhere
because gas is
so [bleep] expensive.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But,
McCarthy's opposition
to the investigation
is also self-interested,
since he was
personally subpoenaed
by the committee
and he told Fox that he
responded to that subpoena
with a bunch of questions.
-Did you receive a subpoena
from the January 6th Committee
and, if so, how did you respond?
-I did receive a subpoena
and I requested --
I asked for information.
Eleven pages, I sent a letter
to this committee.
I sent a letter to this
committee a year ago,
when they asked to talk to me,
and they never responded.
-Probably because your questions
were super dumb.
I mean, I'm just guessing.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm pretty confident
that they were super dumb.
It's like when you invite
your friends to a party
and most people just RSVP,
but then one guy writes back...
[ Laughter ]
"Also, does your house
have European outlets,
or should I bring converters?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, you're obviously entitled
to ask whatever questions
you want, but, ultimately,
it's a subpoena.
You have to comply.
Although, maybe not anymore?
It does feel like this committee
is pretty easy to say no to.
The Justice Department just
announced they won't even charge
two former Trump aides
with contempt of Congress
for refusing to cooperate.
They react the way I do when I'm
trying to get my kids to eat.
Finish your pasta!
"I don't want to!"
Great! Then I guess
you'll just go hungry!
Why don't you go think about it
while you play video games?!
Yeah. Alright.
[ Laughter ]
And when Republicans
aren't actively
obstructing the investigation,
they're claiming
no one's going to watch
because people would rather
spend their time
doing other things.
-This is not
a fact-finding mission.
This is a two-hour,
free documentary sponsored
by virtually every
major network in America,
except for this one,
that's willing to give it
airtime.
The only good thing about it is
most Americans aren't going
to watch this garbage.
Okay, so the question --
does it work?
Do people watch?
-Well, I'd be interested to see
what the ratings
are going to be.
This is kind of like watching --
Are they're going to go watch
"Top Gun,"
which is entertainment,
or are they going to watch
the J6, you know,
TV-produced show?
-Again, you know,
it's not an either/or, right?
You can watch "Top Gun"
and the hearing.
You don't have to pick one.
It's not like people are
showing up to the movie theaters
and the only two choices
at the ticket counter are...
[ Laughter ]
Although, I will say, you got
to see the hearings on IMAX.
[ Laughter ]
That's what everybody --
You haven't experienced
true cinema,
until you've seen a close-up
of Rudy Giuliani's teeth
on a 52-foot IMAX screen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Uhhh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
"Anybody --
Anybody want the rest
of my Raisinettes?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we go back to this?
-This is a two-hour,
free documentary sponsored
by virtually every
major network in America.
-Oh, now, you're suddenly
against TV networks
giving one side free airtime?
I don't seem to remember
you objecting
when Fox aired Trump's
marathon rallies live
or when he used to call in
to "Fox & Friends" once a week
and just scream whatever
the hell he wanted unchallenged
[ Laughter ]
for an entire hour,
while the hosts just sat there
on the couch
with blank stares
on their faces,
[ Laughter ]
like "Jeopardy!" contestants
getting a question
about rap lyrics.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Again, we don't know
exactly what happened
in this hearing tonight
because we're taping beforehand,
but we do know some of the most
important stuff already,
which is that Donald Trump was
at the center
of an attempted coup
to overturn American democracy
and remain in power
as an unelected tyrant
against the will of the people.
He pulled the strings
and his fellow Republicans,
including his friends on Fox,
knew what he was doing,
they knew it was wrong,
and they knew he had
the power to stop it.
Kevin McCarthy even went
out of his way to say
that this can't be swept
under the rug.
They said that
about the insurrection,
the same thing everyone
in the audience
at "The Masked Singer" said
when they heard
Rudy Giuliani's singing voice,
which is...
-This is hurting all of us.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.